[Music]
two top transgender doctors are sounding
the alarm and putting the well-being of
children ahead of the left's radical
agenda in a bombshell interview the
medical experts say we've gone too far
when it comes to the use of puberty
blockers and gender procedures in young
kids but the establishment and the media
won't listen to them why
because anyone who questions whether or
not a nine-year-old is too young to
undergo reassignment surgery or dares
object to a biological male competing in
women's sports becomes a public enemy of
the woke mob no one knows that better
than athletes alana smith and selena sol
they're fighting back against the unfair
competition they join me now along with
their attorney christiana holcomb thanks
so much for coming on alana tell me a
little bit about what's your story and
experience has been
my freshman year of high school i
competed against the two biological
males
and it was just really demoralizing to
know that all of my hard work and all
the other female athletes hard work
wasn't paying off and we were really
just racing for second and third place
and we weren't going to get the spots
that we truly deserved to get
selena tell me about your experience
i was forced to compete against
biological males throughout all four
years of high school and i lost out on
countless opportunities primarily the
opportunity to qualify for the regional
new england championships in the 55
meter dash and if they weren't there i
would have qualified and i've had to
compete against these athletes over a
dozen times and every single time i lost
without fail
christiana it seems to me like this is a
situation where
you're forced to get involved in
litigation and
fights that you never really want to as
a distraction during your high school
years and the like what are the legal
aspects of these fights as you see them
playing out across the country
well girls like selena and alana deserve
to compete on a level playing field and
have the same quality of opportunities
that their brothers have but ben as you
and i both know this issue is so much
bigger than just sports radical
activists including those in the biden
administration are threatening those who
stand up for basic facts about biology
and the fact that humans are either male
or female and you know we see this
ideology play out with real human cost
you know women are being forced and
trapped in prison cells with
violent male criminals we see parents
who are either pushed out of the
conversation entirely or are intimidated
into putting their children on hormones
or undergoing life-altering surgeries
even women are broadly being dehumanized
by being referred to as chest feeders or
birthing people and the list just goes
on and on so that's why alliance
defending freedom and a broad coalition
are standing up for basic truth and
basic biology and to protect women and
girls like selena and alana
alana tell me a little bit and i'll ask
this of you as well selena
what was the reaction among your friends
among your parents among people you
talked to when you tried to talk to them
about the challenge of going through
what seemed to be such an unfair
experience
well my friends and family supported
what i was doing and they thought it was
great that i was fighting for in sports
and ensuring
that we weren't becoming sidelined in
our own sport the only backlash i really
got was on social media from people that
i didn't know
selena was it the same experience for
you
i had a very similar experience as
alanna i've gotten nothing but love and
support from my friends and family my
parents i've been fighting this
alongside with me and i also have only
really gotten
hate from social media but i just focus
on all the love and support
so do you feel like this is one of those
issues where the nationalized nature of
social media the internationalized
nature of it basically allows just about
anybody in the world to take pot shots
at you whether they know you or not
whether they're going to your school or
part of your community or not that
that's really what kind of drives this
discussion now as opposed to letting
places decide let parents and students
decide for themselves how things like
this ought to be governed
i think that social media is a big
factor in this because people get a
boost of confidence by hiding behind a
phone screen but it's just a really
unfortunate situation because it should
be accepted that women's sports need to
be kept as just women's sports
alana in terms of of your own experience
this has to be something that's
discouraging but do you have you taken
some silver lining out of the fact that
you've gotten that level of support that
you mentioned from your friends and
family
yeah it makes me feel really proud that
my story has made it so far and that
hopefully it'll help more female
athletes to stand up so that change can
be made quicker and so that women's
sports can stay women's sports and we
can continue to
compete on a level playing field
you know it really seems to me like this
is an issue that invades our communities
and and creates such uh uh hard
questions for for parents and for
communities to face in ways that are
really unfair to all of the girls who
are involved and i want to thank you
both for being brave enough to stand up
and and to push back against what is an
agenda that obviously has enormous
backing uh from very powerful people but
really doesn't represent what the
communities or parents or even the stu
the female students involved really want
for their communities thank you all for
joining me tonight
thank you thank you thank you
don't go anywhere abby hornacek is here
and she's going to go on the clock
coming up next